vous l'aurez compris l annonce de ce
dimanche donc ces pourparlers qui vont
probablement avoir lieu entre
délégations russe et ukrainienne
probablement à la frontière biélorusse
on a tout de suite prendre la direction
de kiev justement nous attend un autre
envoyé spécial clovis casali bonjour
clovis kovy je le disais on a donc eu il
ya quelques quelques minutes cette
annonce de pourparlers entre russes et
ukrainiens comment cet nouvel état est
accueilli à kiev là où vous vous trouvez
vous
en tout cas je peux vous dire que les
sirènes ont retenti il y à quelques
minutes et on est donc ici à dont l'abri
sous l'hôtel où nous nous trouvons alors
comment cette annonce a été accueillie
et bien je peux vous dire avec beaucoup
de scepticisme alors les plages les
ukrainiens qui nous avons pu a parlé les
plus optimistes les plus optimistes nous
disent que c'est du 50-50 bien sûr il
espère que la paix va pouvoir enfin être
établie va pouvoir enfin revenir ici en
ukraine mais énormément d'ukrainiens qui
nous avons parlé sont méchant ils s'ils
disent qu'ils ne sont pas à des ennemis
à des russes mais qu'ils n'ont aucune
confiance en velay d'ymir bout de
poutine pourquoi est ce que ces
pourparlers marcherait serait fructueux
alors que l'armée russe mènent des
opérations d'envergure un peu partout en
ukraine depuis plusieurs jours
bombardent des immeubles des
installations militaires mais qui ont
aussi fait ses opérations des morts et
de nombreux blessés chez les civils
alors beaucoup de scepticisme ici à kiev
le ministre des affaires étrangères
ukrainien lui à déclare que c'est une
victoire en soi ces négociations car
elles sont sans pré conditions sont un
conditions posées au préalable par les
russes mais il ya aussi de la méfiance
et le ministre des affaires étrangères
ukrainien appelle à ce que les alliés
comme les etats-unis la france
l'allemagne et bien d'autres continuent
d'envoyer des armes à l'ukraine car le
pays en a énormément besoin clovis et
vous nous vous l'avez évoqué au début de
votre intervention un situation toujours
extrêmement tendue dans la dans laquelle
dans la capitale
ukrainienne un nouveau couvre feu donc
est en vigueur il a été étendu hier
qu'elle est là l'évolution de la
situation sur le terrain de ce que vous
avez peut-être pu voir vous
alors les civils et les journalistes ont
interdiction de sortir dehors pendant
cette période de couvre-feu qui dure
jusqu'à lundi sinon on peut nous tirer
dessus c'est ce qu'ont déclaré les
autorités et du coup on passe énormément
de temps ici dans des abris comme celui
où je me trouve où il ya des
journalistes mais aussi des ukrainiens
de tout âge il y a des enfants il y à
des adultes des vieilles dames des gens
qui sont venus prendre refuge ici depuis
plusieurs jours depuis le début des
opérations
alors quelle est la situation on entend
régulièrement des détonations des tiers
des coups de feu des l'artillerie des
tirs nourris particulièrement la nuit
dernière où on a aussi vu de loin est
des roquettes et on a entendu beaucoup
beaucoup de coups de feu une situation
particulièrement volatile ici dans le
pays et à kiev même et ici il y a bien
sûr les soldats d'ukrainiens qui ont
pris les armes pour défendre la patrie
mais aussi de nombreux ukrainiens des
enseignants des coiffeurs des de toute
profession des gens qui sont là pour
dans les rues de kiev pour défendre la
patrie il ya des distributions d'armes
devant certains commissariats à
certaines bases bien précise et je peux
vous dire qu'il ya aussi énormément de
monde qui préparent des cocktails
molotov au cas où il verrait des soldats
russes les ukrainiens se félicite déjà
des bilans si on peut dire des bilans
selon le ministère de la défense
ukrainien et bien il y aurait plus de
4000 soldats russes de tués depuis le
début des opérations est énormément de
blindés et de chars qui auraient été
détruits à ce sont les chiffres
ukrainien est donc pour l'instant les
ukrainiens tiennent bon arrive à
repousser à les assauts russe pour
combien de temps c'est la question merci
beaucoup clovis casali pour toutes ces
précisions clovis cassaigne envoyé
spécial de france 24 donc à kiev donc
encore merci